Hey guys, okay, I'm doing an intro right now for SmartLess and I just got back from the market. I just bought a bunch of tapioca. I got nothing except a brand new fresh out of the oven episode of SmartLess for you guys and a couple of morons to help me with it. Stay tuned. Here it comes. SmartLess.
SmartLess. SmartLess. Hey, how was the golf vacation? How was your golf trip? It was good. It was really, really good. You really missed one there, Arnett. And that's okay.
That was working. I was working. You were busy providing? I thought you guys went together. I couldn't go. No. I tried. I tried.
I was with your wife last night, Jason. Sorry? I hung out with your wife last night and your daughter, who I love. Yeah, she's pretty great. So that was a 10-year-old. That's Maple. The 15-year-old Franny had her sweet 16 this weekend. I know.
I love that. No kidding. She did. And it was... And it's a boyfriend back? Were you back for it? I came back just in time to drive to where she was having it, to kick them all out and lock up.
And it was great. I was ready to see things that I wasn't ready to see, and I didn't see anything that I was worried about. It was very... I mean, there was like bowls of chips and Oreo cookies laid out on trays. You weren't like sweeping up vape cartridges. Exactly. Obviously, I didn't find any.
But like just sweeping up Oreo cookies and stuff, and where was the party? Was it at Sean's house? There were a lot of Cheetos and cookies and pizzas. It sounds like my 51st birthday. Sean, what was the last big party you threw, Sean, for yourself or just in general? For yourself. I don't know. Years and years and years ago.
Why don't... Why don't... Why don't you treat yourself? Why don't... Well, didn't you guys come to that... Remember that poker party that I had? I don't. I did.
Oh my God. Sean, that was 2004. Yeah. I'm not kidding. I know. It was the fall of 2004 in your backyard. I was there. And you remember the year.
You know, we used to play a lot of poker, Will. Why don't we start playing poker again? We talked about it. We've been... We've been threatening. I guess we could do it over here at my house. Why don't we just do it and be fun? Hey, I texted Will yesterday if I could wear these shoes with the suit pants.
Are you wearing... Now, are you wearing them on the flight too? Yeah. Wait, wait, wait. What do you mean flight? What do you mean suit pants? Oh, right. You're taking off today.
He's going to an event. Yeah. Why are you wearing suit pants? And who says suit pants? Aren't they called slacks? Who says slacks? Who says fucking suit pants, bro? Here we go, guys.
Here we are. Suit pants versus slacks. We'll be right back. Who says slacks? Let's go back to the socks. Get back up and let's question the socks. Yeah. Aren't there like little faces on that?
Yeah. What are you doing? What is that? You're just checkers. Are they fun? They're hell's tooth. Do you like people who are like, I'm going to wear fun socks today. And I hope then people notice my fun socks and like go, oh man, you must have a real
sense of humor because I just noticed your socks is really shows that you've got a real sense of humor. You got a lot of character. Wow. You've got a lot of character. Look at the socks. Where are you going, Sean? I'm going to have an event tonight, an award ceremony in Chicago for theater.
It is the events tonight, Sean. The events tonight. Yeah. Wait, what time do you land? Are you nominated or are you presenting? I'm nominated and Good Night Oscar. The show is nominated and Emily Bergle plays. My wife is nominated and the writer is nominated, Doug Wright and Lisa Peterson, who directed
is nominated. Amazing. Are you not nominated? No. I am nominated. Such an honor. Are you also presenting? No.
What time do you get in? You're leaving. You're going to have to land and have to go straight there. Okay. Well, this feels like poor planning. Do you have an acceptance speech written? I mean, just in case I have ideas of just who you want to thank, I saw a look at Sean showed me a copy of his acceptance speech and he actually crossed out Scotty.
He'd crossed. He'd had him in and then he crossed it out. Did you guys get in a fight last night? Yeah, a little bit. No. I want to go back to the socks for two seconds. Let's not talk about the Scotty fight. No, I want to talk about the hurl and Oreo at him.
No. No. I think the socks thing is because we don't, as guys, don't get a lot of, and as far as fashion goes, a lot of room to play with, like it's always just a suit. Opportunities for high drinks. You know what I mean? With clothes. Yeah.
I thought you were going to say it's always just a hoodie. But I do have another hoodie on. Yeah. I do like to accessorize a little bit every once in a while. I don't have the moves that Will does because you're not afraid of a scarf or something like that. Are you Will? Or a cravat?
No. What's a cravat? I don't know. That's God, I guess. I don't know. You know, I get... See the way he was so like trying to have patience with us Philistines that don't know... What can I do?
I mean, you know, I get roasted for it if I just, you know, just for my common parlance. That's why I texted you because out of three of us, you probably dressed the best. You really do. Thank you very much. Thank you for saying that. Yeah. No, I really take that as a compliment. And I did say to you, yes, I mean, I think that those shoes are okay.
Yes. But give me the context where it is. And he said it's this thing. It's not a big deal. And it's in Chicago. And I said that it's fine. Yeah. It's a big deal.
All you heard was Chicago. And it's good then. Yeah. It's in Chicago. Yeah. It's fine. It's fine in Chicago. So they're tennis shoes though.
I'm just kidding. No, all my friends in Chicago, it should be noted, love Chicago. We had a great time in Chicago. The three of us did. We did. And we love it. But Shawnee, those are tennis shoes you're wearing with a suit or am I looking at the full outfit right now?
Is the hoodie part of the... No, no. It's just for the airplane, but what is your opinion, Jason, about like gym shoes with a suit as opposed to like dress shoes? Gym shoes. Those aren't gym shoes. Stop saying gym shoes and suit pants. They're like, you know...
They're... I wore them on the door. What do you call those... What do you call it? You give like rich guys a prom... Sorry. We'll be right with you, yes. Those are like adult contemporary...
I call those adult contemporary shoes. I'm a rich guy with a yacht. Yeah. I'm a finance guy and I'm trying to be cool. And so my wife got me some Tom Ford sneakers. Yeah. And I'm like, hey, look, I'm hip. I don't have time to think about it.
I'm worried about numbers all the time. And then I'm wearing jeans and I'm wearing these kind of sneakers kind of thing. And it's like, hey, listen, I'm wearing this suit jacket, but then I'm jeans under the desk and I got these fucking cool sneaks. Like, okay, just fucking do it or don't. All right. Let's get back to... Why am I so mad about...
And Jason, you know, Jason gets it. You know I'm not mad. I just get worried. I know you're not. I know you're about to get real pleased. Today we have a guest that is all things. She's an actor. She's a producer.
She's a mom, a model, an Academy Award winner, a United Nations messenger of peace and a friend of ours. She's been in 50 films, but is younger than all of us. Let's find out how she gets it all done today on Smart List. Shall we gang? Please welcome the one and only Charlize Theron. Oh my gosh. Yeah.
The deal. Hi, Charlize. Hey. Good morning. She's got a cute haircut and a cute sweater on. Cute haircut today. I do. It's a grow out.
I don't think it's a haircut. It's a grow out. It's a grow out. Yeah. It's a grow out. And it's dark, listener. It looks real good dark. Yeah.
It's super cute. Have I ever seen you dark? I think so. Or brunette. What do we call it? Whatever you want. I mean, I'm not that picky about it. It's just...
It's cold. It's cold. I mean, you're a court baby. Yes, she did. She's got a sweater on that I think I wore in 84. She wears it real well. Thank you. Let's bring those back.
Yes. What about socks? Charlize, are you a socks? Uh-oh. Let me see. Here she goes. No socks. Nothing.
No socks. Look at that. No socks, no shoes. But you got a couple of tats on there. No socks. Yeah. Sean, quick eye there. You noticed, huh?
Yeah. Fast and fast. How many tattoos do we have today? I have two. I'm proud to say. You have a tramp stamp? That's amazing. Yeah.
It's right on the small of my back. It just says breathe. Yeah. What does it say? Breathe. Breathe. So it's working. So it's like a PSA for whoever you're with.
Sean, Will, any tattoos from you two? Just killed Sean. That's hysterical. Sure. Sean's laughing because it's an idea. No tattoos. Right. No tattoos from Will, Sean?
No. I've always wanted to get one. When I was young, I wanted to get one on my bicep. My what? My bicep. And then what happened? It went away. So you had no place to put it.
I wanted to get Wendell Cork. I would be one of those when you're waving. It speaks. It's like a... I know. That's what's happening to me now at 53. I don't like to show my tattoos. Because both are on my girl's names on the inside of my arm there.
I didn't notice how I don't say bicep. And then when I show it to somebody, when they ask, and then that little bottom part of the arm just starts to wave at them, it's not good. I have my girl's middle names on my arm too. Do you? That's cute. Yeah, in charcoal gray right here. But on your forearm?
On my forearm, yes. Okay, so let me ask you, actors with tattoos, do you have to go through makeup when you're doing a movie to get... Like, is it a pain in the ass to get? Yeah, you've got to get it covered up. I did for the first year of Ozark and then I said enough. Let's just say my guy's got tattoos. Who cares?
What about you, Charlize? I did this in charcoal gray, so it doesn't really photograph. It's super light. And so it doesn't... You don't really... You don't pick it up. And I have found as a producer that when they're light like this, it's easy to take them out in the DI.
You don't have to put a ton of makeup. It's almost easier to just leave it alone if it's a light tattoo. But there's also that thing... But I think it started with Mike Tyson and Hangover 3, right, where you have to get the approval or the sign off of the person who does the tattoo. The artist. The artist, yeah. Or they can see you later for like showing a painting that you haven't bought the license
for or something like that. Yeah. Really? It's like playing a song. You've got to pay for it. It's kind of absurd. Remember when shit was free? Yeah.
Right. Just remember when people didn't stress about shit that was stupid? Yeah. I do. Oh, I didn't know that we're all drinking at the same time. Sorry, gang. All right. It's nice to see you guys, by the way.
It's been a while. It's been a long time. Yeah. So long. Many, many years. Many years. I saw you. Remember when she was on Arrested Development, Sean?
What was your favorite scene? Remember when she was on Arrested Development? What was your favorite scene? Oh, my God. It's one of my favorite episodes when she came in. He's never seen Arrested, Charlie. It's a point of contention. She played a character named Rita.
Rita. Who was... It was... Was she... Shirley's, were you... I bet you don't even remember either. I don't... You were a spy?
I... Or we thought you were a spy? You thought you were a spy? You thought I was a spy, yes. Because I had a very interesting British accent. I sounded very smart. Did you have a... Growing up in South Africa, did you have an accent as a kid and got rid of it or what happened?
Oh, yeah. No, I mean, I didn't speak English really until I was like 19. Really? I grew up in an area. Yes. I grew up in an area where... That's right, that's right. That's fucking terrible.
Wait, wait, wait. Come on, Brut. Come on, Brut. Come on, Brut. I know it's a very difficult accent too, South African. Very, very difficult. Anyway, yeah, I didn't speak it. So, I had it as a second language, but nobody in my neighborhood spoke English.
But I went to ballet and there was the Royal Academy of London and so we had these teachers from London and they couldn't speak English. So, that was the only English I ever really heard was these two Brits yelling at me. Oh, that's so crazy. And I would do exams, not even knowing I was doing exams because I didn't understand what they were saying. So, when I came here at 19, it was really kind of like learning the language and that's why it was easy for me to drop the accent because I was really learning English from scratch.
I think English-speaking South Africans have a harder time because it's an ingrained accent that they're trying to break. I didn't have that. So, Africans is a completely different language. It's not a severity of accent. This is new information for you. Wow. It is a combination.
There's about 44 people still speaking it. It's definitely a dying language. It's not a very helpful language. Do we know what it is a combination of? Yeah, Dutch. So, we pretty much all of Europe try to come in and take over. So, the Dutch language is predominantly what it's based on and then there's some German in there and then we've bastardized it.
So, if I understand Dutch, but when I speak Afrikaans, the Dutch person will be like very hoity-toity about it and they'll be like, I don't know what you're saying because we've kind of bastardized it. We've flattened it out a little bit. They might even say that's a terrible, terrible accent like you said to me. Wait, I'm an idiot. Did you ever play a part where you had to do a South African accent? I did, yeah.
You did? Yeah. Probably super famous movie and I'm a dumb dumb. No, it's not actually. It was a film called The Last Face. Okay. Because I could talk to you for nine hours about Alien Prometheus right now because it's one of my favorite movies.
I loved it. Thank you, Scotty. Thank you for sleeping in in the background for some reason. It did look like the door was open. Oh, it's the dog. It's the dog. If it was Scotty on all fours, she's coming to listen. Aw.
All right. Well, okay. So, then you said you came here at 19. Charlize, let's go back. So, we're in South Africa. We decide to go to... Now, ballet was not first. Was it modeling in Milan?
Well, I started dancing when I was really young and then I went to an art school for dance and that's really what I wanted to do with my life. I just, I fell in love with dance and I mean, really what I fell in love with was storytelling, but I didn't know it then because technically I was never the strongest dancer, but when I was Swan Lake, I would fucking die on the stage. And so, I always got work because I could perform. Stop nodding, Sean. Oh, okay.
Sorry. I mean, he's eagerly nodding. But yeah, that's what I wanted to do with my life until I kind of couldn't and had to kind of rethink my life and my mom was the one that pointed out that it was maybe more the storytelling aspect of it that I love than the dance. And so, she was the one that kind of put it together that maybe I should go and try acting, which was like the most stupid, ignorant, like we knew nothing. Really?
Nothing about how you would even go about to be an actor. So, how did you? A one-way ticket to Hollywood. Oh, really? She literally bought me a one-way ticket to Los Angeles. Wow, no way. And I got off the plane and I had nowhere to... I mean, I just had no plan.
I stayed at the farmer's daughter because the cab... On Fairfax? Yeah, and now it's cute. Back then, it was like by the hour. Yeah. I bought a bottle of bleach right across from the Vaughns and started cleaning that bathroom and I stayed there for like six months. I stayed there for an hour once.
Hey, oh, now did you take acting classes right away? Not right away. I had a very strange experience where kind of like the Lana Turner, you know, soda fountain story where I was at a bank trying to cash a check from New York, which was now a state check and I couldn't cash it and this guy was trying to help me cash it and he ended up being a manager. And he signed me on, which is just weird because I could barely speak English and that tells you everything about how we find our actors these days.
But anyway, he told me about an acting class and I started going there like what I could afford, which was like once a week at that time. And that was helpful because I knew nothing about acting. I knew nothing. I didn't even know who actors were. Like I love Tom Hanks movies without knowing his name was Tom Hanks. Oh God, there's so much in there. How long was he your manager, this guy?
He was my manager for about four years. Wow. You're so lucky you found the actual manager that says, hey, young lady, I'm a manager. Like you found a real one. I mean, instead of like in my office is in my van. Yeah, everybody said that. They were like, this guy, this is what happens to everybody. Like you're going to end up in a ditch.
And then somebody actually knew him who was in my car. His card was in my car for like months and they said, yeah, he represents John Hurt. And I was like, well, that's a real actor. Okay. So I called him out. Wow. And we will be right back. SmartLess is supported by Viori clothing.
If you're tired of traditional old workout gear, you got to check out Viori. This is not just me kind of going along some script. This is me saying, do it for real. And you know why? Because I use it myself. Their product is incredibly versatile and it can be used for just about any activity, whether it's hiking or running or training or swimming or yoga or whatever. But it's also great just for lounging or, you know, running around on the weekend with the kids
or just going to the market, whatever it is. Everything they make is designed to look great in everyday life outside the gym. I've got the core short that I wear all the time. I got the long stretchy pants. I've got the pullover zip up thing. All of it. Amazing. I can wear it working out.
I can wear it to drive the kids to school. I can wear it on a Zoom meeting. I guess you could wear anything on a Zoom meeting. But still, the point is it's super versatile. Viori is 100% offsetting their carbon footprint. They are also reducing and offsetting 100% of their plastic footprint from 2019 and beyond. And they're utilizing better sustainable materials for their products, empowering your best act of life.
Feel good about the things you buy and also how they're made, friend. Viori is an investment in your happiness. For our listener, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com. That's B-U-O-R-I. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com.
Visit Viori.com to purchase and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Thanks to Solo Stove for supporting the show. Guys, it's getting cold out and I love it. Finally cooling down. And it's so cozy. It's my favorite time of year. And Solo Stove makes it even cozier. Something special about fall that brings us closer together, right?
And with a smokeless fire pit from Solo Stove, creating those moments is easier than ever. Enjoy all the warmth and comfort of a fire pit plus portability, quick setup and cleaning. And best of all, get this no smoke. You know, I have a friend of mine that has a gorgeous like fire pit in his backyard. And whenever we go over there, it's fun to hang out, but like you end up just smelling like smoke. Like there's so much smoke and it gets all of you closed. You end up smelling like a chimney.
But with Solo Stove, there is no smoke. So I end up smelling like cotton candy and s'mores. Like nothing covers up that smell and it's delicious. Upgrade your backyard with a Solo Stove fire pit and create story worthy moments without the fireside fumes. Stainless steel construction designed to regulate airflow and burn more efficiently. So little smoke, you'll wonder how there's so much fire. It's the perfect catalyst for getting outside and spending more time with family and friends. Build lasting memories around a Solo Stove fire pit.
They're so confident you love it. They offer a lifetime warranty and a 30 day free return policy. Prepare for your best outdoor memories yet and save big during the Solo Stove fall event. Plus use promo code smartlist at solo stove.com for an extra 10 bucks off. That's solo stove.com promo code smartlist for $10 off on top of the fall event deals. Smartlist is sponsored by better help. So guys, don't you wish that life came with like a user manual? There's so many times in my life, especially in this career of Hollywood and like being an actor,
you wish somebody came up to you and was like, hey, avoid this, avoid that, avoid this person, avoid this type of personality, embrace this type of personality. Learn about this business life. Like all of these things you wish somebody would have told you, right? Therapy for me, it helps me just kind of like workout issues. What I do is I write down whatever I want to talk to my therapist about. So when I meet with her, I'm locked and loaded about like all the issues that I want to talk to, like self-empowering myself or dealing with trauma or learning coping skills,
like whatever the issue is I want to, I want to talk to her about. So I'm prepared so that she can be informed and help me better. It's just a little something I do and it's, I benefited from that kind of style for myself. So as the world's largest therapy service, BetterHelp has matched 3 million people with professionally licensed and vetted therapists available 100% online. Plus it's affordable. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to match with a therapist. If things aren't clicking, you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime.
It couldn't be simpler. No waiting rooms, no traffic, no endless searching for the right therapist. Learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com slash smartless. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Now when you, so when you started going to these acting classes and you didn't really know what acting was, you said it was your experience with it and it's starting to become comfortable to you. Did you have the sense like, oh, well, they just kind of have a name for all these things that I'm just kind of naturally doing anyway.
In other words, did you find a very natural approach to acting or were you studying sort of like the technique and like going kind of dot to dot about how to act? Or did it just kind of come naturally to you because you're so good at it and you never really see you acting. It seems like it's very natural for you. Oh, thanks, Jason. I think it was a natural ability. It's easy for me to escape. Like I think I used it in my childhood.
It was a way for me to survive and it's where I've always found solace. And I think of it as this, you know, amazing opportunity that I get to go and do whatever it is at that time, material-wise, that I just get to dive into completely. And I love that aspect of it and that is easy for me. But I didn't know how to break a script down and I didn't even know how to read a script and I didn't know about an arc necessarily. So all of that stuff I had to learn and that's what this class was really helpful for. Because they didn't just have actors, they had writers, they had directors. So I was around people and I could see kind of, you know, from a little bit higher in the ground, not so.
Did you have an early experience with an actor or director on a job where you saw them with the actor maybe breaking down their script or a director sort of, was anybody a real helpful influence for you, like actually at work as opposed to in a class? Oh, yeah. I mean, I think, yes, this class was helpful, but really ultimately I became a student as I was working. I mean, I think that's always the best way to work and I look at all of my experiences early on. I found great mentorship with producers and directors and writers and actors who really, you know, really just took me under my wing. I'm here because of the grace of a lot of those people and kindness of a lot of those people because I was so eager. And so, you know, I think they were entertained by me. Did you have a moment with one of them, though, that you remember now that you kind of go back to and go,
that was a powerful moment, somebody that I worked with, director, writer, actor, early on? Yeah, I mean, I worked with this writer, director, John Hertzfeld. It was my first film that I ever did and he was very kind. You know, he was very patient. I had to do a lot of stuff with James Spader, who's lovely, but like he's a pro, you know? He like shows up and he's ready to rock and roll. And I think I was, you know, like 19 at the time and there were moments where John really kind of like helped me, I think, get through a shoot that could have been tough because I was so inexperienced, you know?
So I'm grateful to him always. But then I got to work with Tom Hanks right after that and he was just fucking lovely because with him, it was just all about the joy. He was just like lean into the joy, the joy, the joy. And then I also had like, you know, counter experiences like I love Taylor Hackford. I did a film called Devil's Advocate with him with Al Pacino and Keanu Reeves and that was a really big movie for me. And he loves, he really encourages method. And so everybody just, you don't really have a choice.
Like that's just kind of like how he makes, I don't know now, but that was back then. So explain for Tracy, the non-entertainment people, what method is? It's basically immersing yourself in the character in the world 24-7. And so you're never, ever out of it. You stay in it. You, your director will call you by the character name. You just, you're kind of immersed in it the whole time. Those people are super fun to hang out with.
Yeah. That's exactly it. So I realized on that film that that was definitely not a process that was going to work for me. There was something so exhausting about it. My life was miserable. I wasn't happy. And then of course you worry because you're like, well, if I don't do that, then maybe I won't be as good as the Marlon Brandos and the Monty Cliffs and you read all these biographies.
And then I did some work non-method and I was actually really happy with the work. And I think you could pop in and out. Yeah. For me, having the energy to be able to go a lot further in darker material is way more helpful than being exhausted. When I'm exhausted, I'm a little bit, I'm just retired. Like I almost like don't want to like go into the dark room. And I think when I, so I made it a real discipline, I think dance really helped me with this. I work and I leave it behind and I come home and I pick up my dog shit
and I love my kids and I make pasta and drink a beer and like life is good. Well, you're so goddamn funny. I wish I wish you do more comedies. I'll bet it's, I bet they just don't come your way, right? I mean, is it just a question of like them not sending you a bunch of comedic stuff? Are you talking to Sean? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. We'll be with you in one second. Like, you know, there it's like, well, maybe you wouldn't mind being immersed in, well, I guess it depends on what sort of comedic character it would be, but going method on a comedy would not be as painful, I would, I would suppose. I think comedy is, you know, it's very much like a taste thing. Like I think you love, you love comedy because you find something funny. And I think that's where I struggle sometimes.
You know, there's certain kinds of funny. Yeah. So like for me, the reason why, you know, I had just won the Academy Award for Monster and the first job I did was working with you guys on a rest of development because, Makes sense. To me, I just thought this is such an opportunity to work with these geniuses that I, you know, might never get again. And then they were, the geniuses weren't available, so you came and worked with us.
You know, Mitch was amazing and kind of like approaching me and saying, like, do you find this funny? Like let's, if you find this funny, we can figure something out. And that's kind of the comedy that I'm, I don't want to, I don't think I can do comedy that I don't myself find funny. Like I loved working with the point gray guys and Seth Rogen on long shot. Like that was a movie that I really loved. I would make that movie over and over and over again because it was just hands down
one of the best experiences, Jonathan Levine kind of shepherded that thing. And everybody was just, I find them very funny. How great is that? Super funny. Yeah. I remember how our minds were blown that you were coming to do the show. Remember, Will, we were just like, wait, what? Yeah.
Charlie's there and it's coming here. Yeah. Yeah. It was difficult. It was difficult. I was so nervous. I'm going to tell you guys right now. I don't think.
It's one of my top five most nervous jobs I've ever done because people don't think of me as funny. So there's this version of like, oh, here comes the dramatic, you know, asshole. That's going to like come and fuck our show up. Yeah. You were just playing this great character. You know, like it wasn't funny to her. You know, that was, that was that band of humor.
Yeah. And that's, I think that's the humor that I like, but I do feel pressure or something. Like I'm not pressure, but you guys are so good. So I look at you guys and I go, I, I, when I watched you two, and not a whole cast, I have to say it's effortless, but I also know you guys have been on the show for a while and you get into a thing. It's like, there's nothing worse than being the new kid on the show. Like when you show up and it's like.
But hopefully you saw how quickly we were all morons and it was just this big dumb family. We were idiots. No, I found you guys very impressive actually. Very impressive. We were very, I remember just being like, what? Just feeling so. I have a question though. You turned into George Michael.
I really did. I did. But I, but what's kind of mind blowing to me just hearing your story about coming here at 19 and not speaking English, you just kind of, it's kind of mind blowing that you jumped into these films like with these huge successful people right away where most actors stories are like, I did this commercial and I tried to get a TV show. I couldn't do that. You know, your, your journey was so quick.
No, I did that. I did that. I just skipped over it. I did, I did like Ross dress for less commercials. Oh, okay. Okay. And by that, I mean, I was like an extra in the back, you know, like not, not featured, but no, trust me, I, I was an extra in children of the corn three.
Oh, okay. I, I, no, it was definitely not like, oh, here you go. Here you go. And what about like roommates? Did you have to find other actor room? Like how was the living situation and growing up? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I've lived in a loft with two other girls right next to the big five down on the San Vicente. Oh, sure. I lived there for years and it was a, you know, like a one bedroom loft. Just, it was just a room and a bed, you know, coming out of the wall and three of us lived there for, for years. The bathroom was literally right next to the kitchen. And I just, I would look at that toilet from the kitchen sink.
And I just, to such myself, let this be the motivation, let this be the motivation. We need to live somewhere where our toilet is right next to the kitchen. That was like, that was a huge motivation. You still talk to them. You and Scotty put a toilet in the kitchen just to cut down the commute, just to cut down the commute. You can only put so much sloppy Joe in your face before, you know, you just can't make it.
They did the math. I don't know how much time they wasted going back and forth. They sat down at a meeting with their business manager. The truth is so funny sometimes. You're right. Charlie's is still trying to catch a breath. We'll wait. We can trim it all out.
I'm literally crying. Oh, God. By the way, I've made these guys sloppy Joe's a couple of times now. So maybe that's why. Yeah. Well, I've heard about your Swedish fish. Yeah. I listened to the show.
The plug that a Swedish fish and a piece of sloppy Joe can make. So, um, Shirley's, um, the, the cushy, uh, uh, uh, shooting situation there at 20th century Fox when we were doing arrested is nothing compared to the grueling location of say a Mad Max. Right. I mean, walk us through. Was that, was it as tough as it looked out there doing Mad Max out in the middle of an Australian desert?
I love that movie. Or was there something really cush just behind camera? No, we shot it in Namibia actually. We were originally going to shoot it in Australia and then. Ask him where Namibia is. Just ask him what side of Africa it's on. Do you know where Namibia is? Over there on the, uh, on the left side.
If you're looking at it from the north. You're right. Yeah. Oh, it was a 50-50 chance. Yeah. We'll see the way I confuse you with the left and the north. I was good. It's a, it's a beautiful place, Jason.
Looks insane. Yeah. It's really beautiful. Um, it's where it's the only place where lions and whales meet. Like you'll see lions walk on the beach and eat, um, you know, discarded whales or. No way. Yeah. It's really, it's a magical place.
There's places called, you know, skeleton coast. And it's like, it's pretty magical. I like that. It has like, like dunes. Like it's just like. Yeah. Sand dunes everywhere. Hundreds of miles of dunes.
I mean, the desert is unbelievable. And we went there because the, uh, there was a flood. There was like a rain monsoon that hit Australia right before, as we were in pre-production. And the whole red desert in Australia just ended up being wildflowers. So not very good. Wow. How long of a shoot was that? Like how many months?
Oh, I just want to listen to this. So we had 140 cars that were made in Australia and they had to ship. They put them all on a boat and drove them on the water. What is that? Oh my God. Sales? Sales them all the water all the way to Namibia. Anyway, uh, what were you asking Sean?
I was just saying how long, the reason why I don't know how long it is. It was long. Like you have to gear up mentally to be out of your house and your comfort zone because like, uh, when I hear about these like year long shoots, I was like, it's, it's so uproots your life. Obviously we're all doing what we love to do, but it's how are you, how do you cope with that? With the uprooting?
Jason, you got a question? I just started to think about the list. What would the list look like in order of heartbreak of the things you would be missing, Sean, from home, if you hadn't been shooting in Namibia? Like what, what would be number one? You'd be like, gosh, I just don't know when I'd get my next. It's my bed. It's my bed.
My bed is like, you know, for the sleep, like you want to sleep in your own bed and you want your own couch. Your bed with your fan and what do you like when you sleep? You need a fan running and what else? I need a fan and I need a pillow between my legs. I need two, like a hard and a soft pillow and a thing. Like, you know, there's a cold. And a bowl full of three musketeer minis.
Well, I got to wake up in the morning. It gets me going. He's got to be within reach at any. It can't be a king size bed. We're not going to get into Sean's rider right now. The point is, but the point is like, you have your. But it is hard going away. Yeah.
Leaving to leave. Yeah. It's really hard. I had my first kid. She was, um, she was literally, I think six weeks old and I, I got on a plane with her as a baby. I was a new mom and I was, I mean, I know Namibia a little bit because most of my family, I was from Namibia.
Namibia used to be part of South Africa and then in the nineties it became independent. So Namibia was kind of familiar to me, uh, but not that familiar, but I also, I mean, I was, I was crazy. I. And Jason, don't get me started because I know, I know what has to be done for you to go away. Yeah. I would not.
I would have passed. I can back you on that. I've been a part of it. It's fucking pathetic. Jason can't even move to the valley. No. Who is fucking kidding? Trust me.
We had to shoot in the valley a couple of times and it was rough. It was rough for him. Uh-uh. That is a word. But it was, it was definitely long and it was the same scenery every single day. It wasn't as long as, it went way longer than we thought. So do you have to like mentally prepare like, okay, I'm going to be gone for this long. I need to, this is how it has to go, whatever my, what's in my room.
And like, you know, just so you can make it home because it's going to be your home. I don't need a lot. I just like, I think for me it was important just to know that I was safe because safety is a bit of an issue there. Yeah. And I had a new baby and that what became the biggest issue. You know, I was, it was just me and Jackson in the house and I got broken in like, you know, three in the morning, like five times.
That was really scary. Over there. Yeah. Broken into while you're sleeping. Yeah. You can hear, like, where are we staying in like a tent? No, I think of this really nice house. Like they have all these beautiful coastal homes like right on the water and they're
gorgeous. I mean, it puts Malibu to shame, but unfortunately you're bringing in a big production. There's money and you were dealing with people who are living way below poverty. And so it's just, it's, it's a recipe for disaster. So that part of it was my biggest concern. And the people that you would ostensibly hire for security would be. They were kind of part of it. Local.
Yeah. Yeah. They were kind of part of the problem. Yeah. I ended up feeling really safe because if you know the movie, the war boys. The majority of the war boys were actually real military, Australian military that George brought out. And so they.
Not to be confused with hot cops, Will. Got it. Got it. Got it. Sorry. But I would text them when I would hear something, I would text them and literally like three minutes later, I would see their flashlights coming in and I just kind of relied on them and they kept me safe the whole movie.
Right. Oh my God. And then you wake up. I mean, that was a very physically like grueling part for you as well. Yeah. Yeah. Right. It was actually cold.
Really cold. It looks hot. Yeah. It was freezing. We had a lot of cases of hypothermia that, especially the young girls who only wear like bandages. Yeah. Like a lot of them got hypothermia. I don't know.
I was freezing just because when you don't have hair on your head, you forget. Like it's like a heat releaser. So it was really cold actually. Now I'd rather freeze than sweat. Absolutely. So like that sounds good to me. Yeah. Absolutely.
Yeah. It's 110. I like it when I'm, when I have to do like action, I like colder better. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Right. For sure.
It's harder for me to have a lot of, a ton of energy to like do fight scenes when it's like I just did this movie in Rome and it was one of the hottest summers. It was 115 degrees every single day. And I had to do these fight scenes out in like these Roman streets and I, it was just like you couldn't keep fluid in your body. And were you wearing clothes and playing a character where you weren't supposed to be sweating? Like that, that's, that's when the heat is dry.
Yeah. I mean, I, after a while I'm just like, I, that's like the last thing I'm fucking thinking about. I'm just the whole cramping. Yeah. I'm like, that's like the last of my, I'm like, can I just be able to walk? Like your feet start cramping because you just have no fluid in your body. So yeah, I definitely prefer a little colder. So many action films.
I mean, are you, you must have been injured beyond any ability to recuperate and keep schedules going forward? I mean, are there any stories of, of you just saying, all right, that's it. We're down for a couple of weeks. No. With an injury. No. I don't know if it's stupidity or if it's just a high, I have a high, maybe a high tolerance
for pain, but I, I, on the first all guard, I tore this, the tendon off this bone on my thumb. It got stuck in a, in a, in a guy's, like his, his, yeah. And it just, he moved and he ripped my whole thumb backwards. Oh my God. And I, I mean, it was really painful. And I just kind of, you know, when you have an injury, you just kind of don't use it so much.
And so I just didn't use it so much, but I had to do like three weeks of a big action sequence on a horse where I was riding with that hand and fighting with the right. And so I was just in denial. And then I came back and, and had surgery. It was, it was just floating. There was like nothing holding it. And I just finished the second one. Now I just came back, uh, like 10 days ago and I just had shoulder surgery to two days
ago. No worries. You're not, you're not, you're not old, but you're not 15. No, I'm not, but you know, I recover really fast and, and I, my body is in great shape. These are all just like superficial injuries. Like I actually, my shoulder is actually great. My knees are great. How's your stunt double doing?
It's little, huh? How's your stunt double doing? Yeah. I mean, I bet you have the same one for years. Listen, she does, she does, she does like, you know, I'm not going to do stupid hard falls down a staircase or like, you know, falling from a second. I don't do stuff like that. But she is, is she still okay?
Yeah. She's, she's fucking 24. I mean, nothing hurts at 24. What about Liam Neeson's stunt double? He must be all banged up. My God. That poor bastard. It's fun to do this stuff.
I like it. I really love it. You need a nice sitcom. You need a nice sitcom. No, I don't know. I don't, I think I'm, I'm not quite ready. I think like another, maybe in another 10 years. Yeah.
There's something so fucking invigorating about hanging off the side of a helicopter. It's amazing. But what about, didn't, you kind of got injured when you put on all that weight for, uh, Sully, right? I had more injuries on that movie. Yes. Just from gaining weight. I, I had to herniated a disc at my lower back because I just,
We had that happen. Well, I gained like 50 pounds and then I had to wear a pregnancy belly that Jason Reitman, the director thought would be a good idea to make the actual size, the weight of the actual, so weighed like another 40 pounds. And then he put me in a fitting and I had to put shoes on over and over and just, you know, from bending and putting on shoes. I herniated a disc in my lower back and that's been the worst injury I've ever had. Wow.
We'll be right back. We get support from Thuma. Your bedroom deserves a refresh, right? And now is the perfect time to elevate the most important room in your home with Thuma. Introducing the bed by Thuma, handcrafted from eco-friendly, high quality upcycled wood. You'll find beautiful, unique variations in the natural grain. The minimalist design featuring Japanese joinery helps elevate any space. It's super supportive for your mattress, breathable and made to naturally minimize noise
and create space. The perfect platform bed frame just got better. You can now customize the bed by choosing between their original pillow board or their new solid wood headboard. Made for how you live, the bed by Thuma is backed with a lifetime warranty, ships right to your door in three easy to maneuver boxes and takes about five-ish minutes to assemble with no tools required. You can easily build it yourself.
So like I got one, I'm setting it up in my room because you know Scott and I sleep in separate rooms because of the snoring. We both snore. We wouldn't be together if we slept in the same bed. It would just be a nightmare. So he walks in, he sees me setting mine up and he's like, do you need help? I'm like, no, look at me. Look at this body.
Look at how I'm doing this all by myself. Look at my fat stomach hanging over the side of this gorgeous walnut finish. I mean, clearly I don't need anybody's help. And then I was like, can you get this other side? No, I did it all by myself. It was like so easy and it did. I actually did it under five minutes because I'm fast. But anyway, create that feeling of checking into your favorite boutique hotel suite, but
at home with The Bed by Thuma. And now go to Thuma.co slash smartlist to receive a $25 credit towards your purchase of The Bed plus free shipping in the continental U.S. Go to Thuma.co slash smartlist. That's Thuma.co slash smartlist for a $25 credit. Hey, smartlist listener. We're brought to you in part by G4. G4 is a crowd pleaser.
They've got men's and women's apparel footwear and golf accessories. And right now G4 has teed up some new limited edition releases just in time for my spouse them for me for the holidays. Plus get ahead of the gifting game and enjoy complimentary shipping on your order. Looking for a big showstopper gift? Try a personalized golf bag. Or maybe you need a last minute stocking stuffer, a new colorful golf glove or a putter cover as sure to please check out their holiday gift guide for the avid golfer or golf fan in your life.
Need some more wrecks? The classic Gallivant or golf shoe style is a crowd pleaser with optimal traction. And their MG4X2s are great for on and off the course, making them ideal for the casual golfer. So it's really, really cool. And I can't wait to put it on my body. Check out their site and order soon to ensure your gifts are delivered before the holidays by going to GFORE.com slash smartlist to get 10% off your first order today. One more time.
That's G4.com slash smartlist. Smartlist is supported by Audible. You don't ride an elevator for the music, do you? Or pick an airline for the movies. So when it comes to audio entertainment, it makes sense to choose Audible. Get it? It's the home for stories told by the biggest stars like Ethan Hawke, Carrie Washington and Kevin Hart. It's home to epic adventures, chilling mysteries and can't miss comedies.
Audible is the home of storytelling. Let your imagination soar with audiobooks, podcasts and originals. So everybody knows in Los Angeles, you drive a lot, right? So you spend like, I don't know, half your life it feels like inside your car. So what I do is I stick on Audible and I put on like one of those like true crime things or better yet, a sci-fi thing. And I completely lose myself in the imagination while focusing on the road. But I lose myself in the stories. You know what I'm saying?
Like the sci-fi, like how deep it goes into some of those shows is like really, really, really cool. I really get off on that stuff. Audible is the home of storytelling with all your audio entertainment in one app. Find the best of what you love or something new to discover. Audible has an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business and more. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases.
Members also get full access to a growing selection of included audiobooks, Audible originals and podcasts. You can download or stream our included titles all you want. One of the things I'm listening to and loving is Stephen King's fairy tale. Somebody asked him like what he wanted to write during the pandemic, like what he wanted to do the most and this was it. And I was like, oh my God, I got to check this out. It's fantastic. Let Audible help you discover new ways to laugh, be inspired or be entertained. New members can try it for free for 30 days.
Visit Audible.com slash smartlist or text smartlist to 500-500. That's Audible.com slash smartlist or text smartlist to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartlist. All right. Back to the show. Can I tell you something? This is a true story. Okay.
First of all. We're going to listen harder. Thanks for stopping lying. Go ahead, John. This is a true story. I was sitting there watching because you have this unbelievable ability to like we spoke about earlier to lose yourself into every character you play. It's very rare that, you know, there's Philip Seymour Hoffman who was just like transformative. There's you who's always transformative.
It's just an incredible feat. So I'm sitting there with Scotty, my husband watching bombshell. I swear to God, I'm not making this up. And like half hour, 40 minutes in, I'm like, where the fuck is Charlie Stern? I thought she was in this movie. And he's like, what, you idiot? That's her. And I'm like, as Megan Kelly, I was blown away.
I mean, you look like her. You sound like her. It was so funny, you guys. I think it's like amazing. I don't fuck them. I'm enjoying this moment, Charlie. I'm just looking at your screen right now. It's just me and you.
And that's all I wanted to say. I don't have a question. Like I really truly was like, I thought Charlize was in this movie. That's nice. That's her. It is pretty impressive. I mean, it was mind blowing. What about this new thing, a school for good and evil?
What are you doing in that? And what, why'd you want to do it? What, what, what about it? Was it Paul Feig? Cause he's a good dude. Yeah. He did our, he did a couple of episodes of our aggressive element. Yeah.
Yeah. He's such an amazing guy. I also just, you know, I have two young kids now, seven and 10. And they're going to have to be like, at least, you know, 52 to see any of my work. So there is a level of wanting to make stuff for them because they, they love this world, this kind of fantasy world. And it was also, oh, fuck man. It was like towards the end of our lockdown and I was going star crazy.
I was homeschooling the two of them. And I obviously couldn't take a job because I didn't want to move them. You know, it just wasn't the right time to move a whole family somewhere. So it was a two week job up in Belfast. And they got me back in 14 days and my mom took the kids. And so that was nice too. But yeah, mostly I did it for them. I, I want, you know, there's something, I don't know, there's something about,
you know, kids that no matter who you are, you want to impress them. Like they're not impressed by Megan Kelly. Right. And it's also proof of like, well, this is, you know, mom is busy, but I swear I'm busy doing stuff. I swear it like, here's something you can see. It's proof. Well, they see the posters when we drive to the bus.
They never see the movies, right? But they always see the posters and they spend time on set and things like that. So they think they know what the movie is. And it's really funny when they're like, they see the poster and they just go, well, I don't know if that is the movie that I saw you make. All right. How do you manage to do all of this work and still be such a great mom? Because I know you put an incredible time and focus to being an incredible mother.
And I know that you've got incredible help from your mother who is an incredible woman. But like, but as I said in the intro, 50 films, like it takes a few months to do a movie, especially when you're the lead, like you always are. Like the math doesn't even work out. I don't know how you've gotten all that done and still been, you know. Well, I've been producing for, you know, close to two decades now. And I think that's really helped just taking some agency and making my own schedule. And so I really don't make anything like, I don't make any big movies unless I, you know,
I push it into the summer where I can take my whole family. Like we all went to Rome for four months and, but, you know, I get my kids back for school, but you're right. I can't do it without my mom. And I'm always very vocal and acknowledging that I am co-parenting with her. So that's kind of unusual for people to hear, but that is the truth. She really is, is very much a co-parent. I got that.
Yeah, it's amazing. I'm so lucky. I'm so lucky. How much of, how much, because your mom's been there obviously the whole time and, and you are so close to her. How much do you talk to her about what choices you make as a, you know, sort of artistically as a producer or as a, as an actor? Do you have a relationship like that at all?
Do you go like, Hey, I'm thinking about doing this thing. What do you think? Do you take, do you sound stuff off of her in that way too or no? So when I started, she was definitely, she was way more opinionated. I mean, she definitely, she's, she's very direct. Jason, you've met her. She's very funny. She's very direct.
She's kind of, she's a broad. She's very, very brassy and loud and she loves to swear and she's just very honest. So in the beginning, when I started, there was a lot of like wanting her approval, but she would go and see some of my movies and just be like, that's a piece of shit. Before you even had the theater. Yeah. And I was like, you should come out and you could just tell on her face. She was like, that is not good.
But I appreciate it so much from her. It's kind of our relationship. I remember as a dancer too, when I was little, like I would have a competition or something. She was never the parent that would sugarcoat it. She wasn't like abusive about it, but she was very honest. I knew that when she said something was good, I was like, fuck, that was, then that was really good. Yeah. You know, like I really believe that more than the negative stuff.
It becomes like a real barometer for you. Exactly. I can really trust her. So it's not so much, I mean, I tell her obviously because she's part of it. I have to like clear her tennis and golf schedule out here so that she can like, you know, pack up and move with me. But yeah, she likes a lot of stuff. She loves, she loves like the long shots. She likes those kind of movies way more.
Yeah, yeah. But she loved this movie, this fantasy movie, this school for good and evil. She really loved it. I can't wait to see it. She's a big golfer. She's a big golfer. We need to double back to that. She's a big golfer and a really big tennis player.
She's super athletic. She's going to be 70 next year, but she plays with 30 year olds. I mean, she's, she hikes every morning at 5am, 3 miles every morning with six dogs. She takes my dogs and her dogs. Wow. And then soon she walks 18 holes and then she plays tennis. No golf, no tennis for you? I only play golf with her and usually just on Mother's Day and I, but I love tennis.
But tennis is like a later sport that I just learned because I had to find something for cardio because I couldn't really run anymore. And so I found tennis and I was like, this is great cardio and I enjoy it. Tennis is great. What about the pickle ball? We play a lot of golf. Jason and I play a lot of golf. No, not pickle ball. No pickle ball.
No, I mean, isn't that like what bowl people play? Yes, I think so. It's sweeping the nation just because it's easy. It's really sweeping things. Americans really love to fucking glom on this. Do you guys play pickle ball? I have played, Sean's got a pickle ball court and a toilet right in the middle of the court. I'm up for pickle ball.
I would love to learn. I played before, I've played pickle ball before. It ruins your tennis game. I don't advise it if you like tennis because it engages the wrist too much. I like ping pong. I used to play paddle a lot. Anybody like ping pong? Oh, I love ping pong.
I have a ping pong table in my backyard. Are you trying to just bring up stuff that you don't have to move at all? Yeah. Just my upper body. Xbox. What about that? I play that. TV.
I like watching TV. Now, you seem like such a brave person. What scares the hell out of you? What are you most afraid of? What's like you cook the night? I have a great question. She does seem like a very brave person. Oh, she's nice.
But it earned bravery, though. It's not fair. I kind of threw up in my mouth a little bit there. I mean, moving when you're 19, you can't speak English. You're making that. Yeah. I mean, a lot of that when I think back and now that I have kids, I'm like, God, it was just, I feel like, you know, if I didn't come out of the circumstances that I did,
no, my mom would have never done anything like that. And I don't think I would have done anything like that. But I came out of very complicated circumstances. You know, I didn't really, there wasn't a lot of choice. It was like swim or drown. Like what are you going to do staying? Yeah, you're tough, though. You seem very, you're very tough.
Like you have this, you can kind of see it. It's kind of resolved, this inner resolve that come, for me anyway, I've felt like it's always shone through. And you see him. I'm like, oh yeah, yeah. She's on top of her shit. She's very tough. But like, don't talk to her.
Well, yeah. What about like bees? Cause like bees, bees will turn me into somebody I don't want to be seen. I think I've seen you like scream like a girl. I think I have. Yeah. And I'll just run. I'll just, I'll just disappear like with like a rocket flare, like a cartoon character.
I tell you, I saw a cockroach yesterday and I did not handle it well. Yeah. I'm not good with those guys. I did not handle it well. I really could not. I didn't know what to do with it. I didn't want to kill it, but I also didn't want it to live. I was really, I was very, really torn.
And then I just, the idea of stepping on it. Oh, I couldn't. It was like. What did you do then? I made somebody else do it. Yeah. You called somebody in and did you, did you, did you instruct them not to kill it? No, I was with a number of people.
No, this was one lady was really brave. She just, she stepped on it. I was like, I'm going to get my shoe off and just did it. I was very grateful. Yes. Is there anything, is there anything within sort of what you, the realm and the, you know, the bigger scope of what you do. So again, as a sort of, as an actor or a producer, a writer, director, whatever, is there anything
that you can think of that you think that seems scary for me to do? Would you dance or sing? I mean, I would dance. I would love to dance. I don't know. I don't think I would sing. I'm a terrible singer. Me too.
Yeah. And I'm very uncomfortable singing. Like I break out in hives. That's why Jason Reitman always makes me sing in his movies because it's, he just loves torturing me. But I don't know. I mean, listen, I was really, I was really worried, scared. I was scared of doing Mike and Kelly. I really, I, you know, that's, it's one of those things where you're like hoping for
the best and you try and do as much work as possible, but there's no guarantee, right? And it's like, you go, you're like four or five weeks in and you still don't sound like her. And I did the first round of prosthetics and I looked like Glenn Close. Like it was weird. Like I was like, I don't know if this is going to work out. And so you feel like, you kind of feel like you're out on a limb and you're without a neck.
This can definitely go very wrong. Like I definitely felt that. How about when in Prometheus, when you just lit some guy up on fire, that was like, you had like a fire machine and the guy was standing, was it a fire machine? Whatever it's called. I didn't really do that. Oh, you didn't get a fire gun. You had like a fire.
You know, they actually, that one did, that did light up minus like there was nobody in front of me, but it did light up. I think they did one where it kind of lights up a little bit. And that was pretty bad. Oh, so that wasn't you just like blowing them to bits like that, lighting them on fire? No, they added that later. Oh, wow. I'm so sorry, Shirley.
Holy f***ing good. I love that movie so much. You do? That's so sweet. Oh my God. Welcome to Fan Fest. I love that you go between Meg and Kelly and that. I've seen Prometheus like 10 times.
I didn't love it. And you know what's wild? I mean, that Fassbender is pretty amazing. I did a deep dive on YouTube about it because the engineer, I don't know, you're never mind. These guys are going to fall asleep and finish it. No, we want to hear it so bad. Let's have it.
I want to know. I heard that he was diving on YouTube before. I don't know if this is true or not because Ridley Scott had, I don't know if it's true, but I heard that he had this original script that explained kind of the whole, they gave this engineer, this dialogue that explained the whole movie, but he cut it, which was that in the Bible, when Jesus was in there for however many years, because you know, the Bible cuts from when he was a kid to 30, that these engineers, these aliens came, picked them up, brought them to their planet, taught them how they should teach humanity, brought
them back. And then that's what he tried to do, but they failed. And that's why these aliens want to come back and wipe it out because it's gotten so bad. And you heard this where? What? Online, somewhere. Wow. I can't verify that for you.
That's really interesting. It's fascinating, isn't it? I fucking... And if it's not true, it's a good idea. That's a great idea. The world is round too, Sean. It's round. It's where?
But anyway. I think some listeners right now are, like, touching themselves. Like, you know, people really appreciate that kind of knowledge. Thank you. They're really touching themselves, like, am I fucking here? Is this... Is this actually... Did I just pass out?
What am I... Did I... Yeah. I didn't know if you knew... If you heard that, if that was true... No, I did not. No, you know why? Because she doesn't spend her time on Reddit with you and Scotty.
Going fucking putting in Prometheus fucking theories. Chat rooms. Scotty, we should get to bed. It's 4 a.m. Yeah, but look at this thread. Look at this fucking thread. Fucking fuck, man. It's bad.
That stuff is fascinating to me. I know, Angel. I know. All right. All right. Charlize, you're the greatest. Yeah. You're the best ever.
Guys, I really love this show. Congratulations. We love you. I listen to it all the time when I start waiting to pick my kids up. It's a joy to listen to you guys. You're really funny. Thank you. Thanks for having me.
Yeah. And thank you for having me. I guess you ran out of people. Yeah. Every time I would listen to it, I thought, yeah. How dare you? Yeah. We're on the tease.
Between Jason and Will, between both of you, I could make... It's Will, but that's... Will, that's how we say it in Afrikaans. I was like, wow. I'm like, you guys must have really cleared your list. Even you, Sean, I know you too. Like, what the fuck happened? Can I tell you something?
What is it? Season 17? No, can I tell you something right now? You've been on my list since day one. And obviously, Jason, you were on Jason's list as well. Yeah. And I was like, no, I get her. So, Will is the one that we...
I don't know. I had a different list. And then it just... I don't know. I didn't have a pen. I didn't end up having a pen. Well, thank you for having me, you guys. Yes.
We love you. Have a great rest of the day. Love you. Right back. You guys too. Thank you for doing this. All right. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. We had great directors. We sure did. The Rusev Bowl. What's the name of the show? Oh, man. Oh my God.
It's so... Should we come over? We should come over. We'll go over to Shawn's house. We'll watch some rest of development. And then you come over to one of our houses. We'll watch Will and Grace together. We'll watch Will and Grace.
That sounds like a fun... We'll make a new podcast out of it. Yeah. You know, a little watch through. And we'll sign it. We'll sign the contract that we each... We're all gonna watch it. And that contract will be binding.
Binding. You guys, I fucking, I was crying, laughing so hard, good God. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast.
Smart. Blast. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Blast. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.